[Music]
let's start this hour with tyler in
riverside california hey tyler what's up
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um so so my husband and i are in a
little disagreement about where we
should invest our money in the future
i want to invest into
and he you want to invest into what your
phone cut out
oh i want to invest in mutual funds
and he wants to only invest in the
property because he's afraid of doing
the stock market and everything
so i just want to know like what how we
should go about that or if we can do
both even if we're not very
knowledgeable about it or how i can talk
to him about how it works
well investing in real estate um
unless you have the money to pay cash
for it
is not what we would recommend
uh
borrowing money to go into real estate
is a lot more risk than anything the
stock market represents as far as risk
goes
um so but paying cash for some rental
properties and having some mutual funds
in your roth iras and 401ks is a great
idea a good mix of that that's what i
personally have
um and so yeah doing both would be you
know what
if if that's what each of you kind of
your husband has more of a real estate
idea and you have more of a mutual fund
idea then i don't know why you can't do
both is he completely opposed to putting
any money into the stock market
he's really worried about it
even when i try to tell him how it works
from based on just you know what i hear
from you
knowing that oh we don't have to worry
about it we have to do it ourselves once
he's in there for 20 to 30 years we know
it's going to be good but
he
he really thinks because it goes up and
down that if it goes down it could crash
and it'll just all be bad okay but based
on what is it going to crash what is he
basing that on because it never has
except except 1928.
okay so he's he's
i think he's just in the back of his
mind that anything could happen if we're
not looking at it or anything could
happen if you the word
yeah i really don't know how to convince
him because he's
he's very scared of
putting it somewhere where someone else
is moving it and we're not
the ones doing it well you should be
doing it you need to be picking the
mutual funds but just like you pick a
neighborhood
to buy real estate in how old is your
husband
he's 30. what does he do for a living
um he's a bike salesman right now okay
all right so here's the thing there's
two kinds of fear
a fear that is a reality that's like
don't touch a hot stove don't stand in
the middle of the interstate with an 18
wheeler coming at you okay that's that's
fear that's reality and you want to
avoid those kinds of fear
and that's fear telling you how to
survive right the other kind of fear is
false evidence appearing real
and so what it amounts to is he's hurt
his buddies at the bike shop
who are financial idiots
talk about how the stock market's going
to crash
and they have no idea what they're
talking about
and so he needs better sources of
information he needs to learn some more
because the more knowledge you have i
mean the first time you get uh behind
the first well use a metaphor that works
here the first time you get on a bicycle
when you're learning to ride a bike when
you're four or five or whatever it is
right
it you're afraid
but then once you've done it a long time
you have knowledge about how the bicycle
works
and
you're now functioning and so all he's
lacking here is knowledge he's not
basing this from what you're describing
on anything uh
other than a vague feeling
right
yeah yeah and you don't need to make
decisions in your life on anything on
vague feelings and so i would just
encourage both of you to continue the
learning process and
yeah i would have some real estate in
there if you're willing to pay cash for
it
but if you guys are just now getting out
of debt and you don't have a big pile of
money you're probably not going to be in
the real estate market for a while and
buying real estate on
debt is much riskier than the stock
market is you're asking for it when
you're doing that so we tell people not
to do that i don't do that tyler i would
suggest two things one if you've never
contacted and met with one of our smart
vester pros go to ramseysolutions.com
set up an appointment and maybe set up
two or three so that he can sit with you
in the office of one of our smartvestor
pros and let them answer all of his
questions is my new
the minutia to the broad that's the
first step but i also tell him to go in
there not don't buy anything yeah this
is information this is a
we're gonna go to class right we're
gonna and you're gonna do this as a
favor to me right then the other thing
is i'm gonna t dave up really quick
tyler because uh over the course of
50 60 years what's been the average rate
of return on the stock market a little
over 11 close to 12.
he's got it she's got to speak in super
simple terms almost the ross perot
poster board here's the graph here's
what it's done over a long period of
time simplicity will help
yeah but i mean it it's you just learn
the history of something that's right
and then you don't worry about it you
know
as much because you're you're then
you're you're
you know facts are your friends
fear is not your friend